you think a lot of people have that
where they're like what I'm doing is
meaningless I think everything's
meaningless and then we can just create
whatever meaning we choose to if we
don't believe in a capital M meeting
which a lot of people disagree with
that's fine I think that's very freeing
because then you can create Little M
meaning for whatever you want and this
is kind of like the basis of nihilism
which people have like a very negative
Viewpoint around which I'm not entirely
sure about why Capital meeting means
that like this is the meaning of life
period for everyone whereas if we say
that there is no single agreed upon
meaning of life and then people say well
then that is your big meaning of life
and I'm like yes you're right I believe
that there is no meaning and they're
like well then that is the capital then
sure that's my capital A meaning is that
there is no meaning what's the
implication of that now that we have
meaning making machines in our brain we
get to create and Destroy meaning as we
see fit